en vídeos anteriores hemos hablado un
poco sobre la distancia recorrida en
contraste con el desplazamiento lo que
voy a hacer en este vídeo es revisar
estos conceptos sobre la recta numérica
de una dimensión y seremos un poco más
matemáticos en este vídeo así que aquí
está mi recta numérica digamos que aquí
está en 0 1 2 3 4 y así continuamos y
luego en la dirección negativa 1
negativo 2 negativo y 3 negativo y
digamos que empezaremos con un limón y
queme limón está justo en el cero de mi
recta numérica y digamos que primero se
mueve 2 hacia la derecha al inicio lo
movemos 2 hacia la derecha y eso lo
denotamos con + 2 y luego desde ahí lo
movemos 3 a la izquierda y voy a usar
negativos para la izquierda así que se
mueve 3 a la izquierda y después digamos
que se mueve 1 más a la izquierda
uno a la izquierda y lo voy a denotar
con un uno negativo porque se mueve a la
izquierda así que con base en lo que
sabemos sobre la distancia recorrida y
desplazamiento cuál es la distancia
recorrida por este punto distancia
recorrida
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
recuerden que la distancia recorrida es
la longitud total del camino o la
longitud total del viaje del punto y va
a ser igual a 2 a la derecha + 2 y luego
3 a la izquierda este es un concepto
importante cuando hablamos de distancias
no decimos si son positivas o negativas
sólo nos interesa el valor absoluto de
lo que hemos recorrido así que no
especificamos la dirección ahora podrían
decir hoy en donde se especifica la
dirección bueno implícitamente si algo
es positivo o negativo en esta recta
numérica eso nos da la dirección pero si
estamos hablando de distancias entonces
la dirección no nos interesa solo nos
interesa la magnitud así que esto será
dos más tres más uno no importa si es
uno a la izquierda o uno a la derecha
tampoco importa si es uno positivo o uno
negativo nos interesa su valor absoluto
nos interesa su magnitud así que la
distancia recorrida en este ejemplo
igual a seis unidades cualesquiera que
sean las unidades si son metros entonces
esto sería seis metros
ahora cuál es el desplazamiento
recuerden que el desplazamiento es el
cambio neto en la posición
desplazamiento
cuánto será pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo bueno el desplazamiento va
a ser igual a la posición final y
usaremos x digamos que este es el eje x
así que x final nuestra posición final
menos nuestra posición inicial en
realidad es sólo el cambio de posición
así que cuál es el cambio de posición
aquí bueno nuestra posición final es
estamos en 2 negativo x es igual a 2
negativo y cuál era nuestra posición
inicial iniciamos en cero así que 2
negativo -0 es igual a 2 negativo como
visualizamos esto en nuestro dibujo
bueno empezamos aquí simplemente piensen
cuál es nuestro cambio neto de posición
empezamos aquí y sin importar cuál fue
la trayectoria terminamos 2 a la
izquierda así que nuestro desplazamiento
es 2 negativo ahora para el
desplazamiento no sólo nos interesa la
magnitud nos interesa la magnitud y la
dirección así que probablemente digan
bueno donde se especifica la dirección
si sólo dice 2 negativo bueno en este
caso unidimensional el signo nos está
dando la dirección el signo nos indica
dirección
empecé con esta noción implícitamente
que el negativo es a la izquierda y el
positivo a la derecha y estamos en este
mundo unidimensional y esas son las
únicas dos direcciones en las que puedo
viajar así que si estoy en este mundo
unidimensional o si estoy pensando solo
en una dimensión el signo me da la
dirección y es la razón por la que en el
desplazamiento donde me interesa la
magnitud y la dirección el signo si me
importa mientras que en la distancia
donde solo nos interesa la magnitud no
nos importa cuál es el signo simplemente
sumamos las magnitudes y de esta manera
primero nos desplazamos 2 a la derecha
esto es + 2 el signo + nos indica a la
derecha luego nos desplazamos 3 a la
izquierda así que es menos 3 y luego
tenemos un desplazamiento de uno a la
izquierda nuevamente menos 1
por eso estamos hablando de
desplazamiento y nos interesa el signo y
si sumamos todo esto vamos a obtener el
desplazamiento neto 2 negativo pero una
manera más sencilla de obtener el
desplazamiento es la posición final
menos la posición inicial